here we go all right are you ready oh
good evening everybody
welcome to the Development Committee
17th October 2019 as usual ha emergency
evacuation announcement should we be
required to evacuate the building
would you please leave the building via
the nearest available exit of chamber
our assembly point will be in the public
car park at the side of the Civic suite
please don't delay your evacuation by
collecting belongings please don't
return into the building until given
permission to do so by council staff
please also note that the meeting won't
be audio recorded and reminder to turn
your Mobile's to our for silence please
can I just check that all members of the
committee have seen the addendum to
sheets that's put in front of you yeah
senior chance Rogers thank you
item 1 then apologies for absence have
been received in the office from
councillor Weston we don't have a
substitute member or non-members
attending a councillor Newport Steptoe
and Macpherson item 4 minutes of the
meeting oh hello yes sorry big fun Thank
You chairman sorry Craig Cornell can't
make it tonight
oh right okay thank you additional
apologies act now
after item four minutes of the meeting
calendar on the 29th of August 2019 a
happy for me to correct that sign those
as a correct and accurate record of that
meeting thank you
item five his declarations of interest
members we we've had advise that for
item 10 one all members have a
non-pecuniary interest due to the
council strategic housing team having an
interest in the site so do you mind if
we just take that one on Massa's
declaring that interest for all members
of the committee
okay thank you that's a step toe Thank
You chairman a little bit of a list item
six as Ward and County member for the
area the same with items seven County
member for item eight just making sure
and warden county member for item ten
one but they don't okay okay I'm not
entirely sure on the protocol is a
visiting member but just for just for
transparency no chairman I was checking
that very fact that we don't have okay
thank you thank you
right our first item is one that's
coming back to us item six cherry oak
cherry orchard brickworks
Cherry Orchard Lane Rochford so mrs.
Frank's is taking us on this one Thank
You chairman just to refresh members the
application site you'll hopefully be
able to see roughly edged in red there
on the plans Cherry Orchard Lane running
down generally north to south the edges
of the aviation way and built up parts
of South End to the north Stroud green
the [ __ ] public house and haul road with
the fairway development just off the end
there this application relates to the
form of brick field site that members
will recall the kilns and areas were
demolished some time ago
and the application came in has been to
committee twice actually November and
June this year the application is an
outline application whereby only the
access which we will touch on is up for
consideration so you're dealing with the
principle of the development and then
the access which there are some issues
around and then the remainder of the
plan that you're going to see in layout
is an indicative plan just so that the
applicant can demonstrate to members
that the quantum of development fits the
site to give you some numbers it's a
proposed retirement village it would
have 32 apartments for the over 55:22
Wellings for the over 55 s9 bungalows
for the over 55 s 30 number assisted
living apartments 35 sheltered
apartments a 93 bed care home and 903
square metres of shop space 397 square
meters of a 3 restaurant space or CAF
1974 square metres of business space 890
square metres of clinic D 1 use type
space and 197 car parking spaces we show
you a indicative layer of that in due
course the application assay was
deferred on the 27th of June to allow
officers to consider the revised device
from central government on the provision
of elderly care and the outstanding
comment from the county highway
authority which members will say is
expressed in the report that's been
updated if we can jump to this
indicative plan Cherry Orchard line we
see here the existing access for the
adjoining development to the south the
applicant has colored up the neighboring
development you're looking if you can
see the red line at this area here which
is the brick field area he's included
the adjoining Airport Business Park
development and shown it in the same
kind of line densities and qualities but
you're not considering the entirety of
what you can see backgrounded yellow and
gray you're considering this corner up
here and it goes round the terrace of
cottages that exists there it doesn't
include those and you'll see the line
goes west
of an area of land here that the
applicant has demonstrated is having
some kind of potential but that is also
outside your sight and just out of
interest it is not included in the
permission that was given for this bit
so it's a it's a spare piece of land
that the applicant is suggesting could
have potential commercial development as
well just to orientate ourselves the b1
type uses and the a1 uses are generally
described as to probably being held in a
building something like this at this
part of the site there is a a creche
that's been approved as a separate
consent which is on that part and then
the balance of the residential and care
uses would be in the middle parts of the
site hopefully that is clear I don't
know if it's possible to zoom in on that
part give members a bit more detail if
that's possible yeah that's that's good
can you go another jump thank you that's
great while we're on this image it's
worth pointing out two members talked
about that for you tonight is to
consider access you'll see that the main
roundabout that's already been put in
comes into this adjoining site and
you'll see an access through here this
is the only one that the county highway
Authority in the recommendations to you
will actually accept you'll see the
applicant proposes an access through
here off Cherry Orchard way another one
to where the nursery school building is
and another one just here now County
they raised no objection to this scheme
in highway terms but it's on the caveat
that these Western access points would
not be used
the only exception they would allow is
for the nursery school to enjoy its own
little access there and car parking but
that is not in highway view to connect
up to give permeability for vehicles
they're happy with cycles and footpath
links that's good planning but they want
the highway movements to come in off the
main roundabouts come into this
development go round that roundabout and
out through there it's worth dwelling on
that just a moment if members are clear
we're off officers recommending approval
to you tonight we would be able to
condition that this be the only access
if members were to agree so the fact
that we're talking about access and that
these the highways
authority don't accept doesn't stop you
from granting planning permission on
highway grounds there is no highway
grounds two objective at least from the
highway authority providing this is
condition that would be the sole access
if we could jump to the jack please
proposals map the starting point for any
planning and application that we have is
an authority is the development plan and
Rochford in addition to our allocations
plan that's district-wide
we have the joint area action plan the
[ __ ] that has a focus on the airport
environment and to do with the expansion
of commercial interests and potential
for land that's associated with airport
uses or business uses in the synergy
that goes on with that this document was
subject to public consultation and the
usual local plan process it would stood
scrutiny by a government inspector and
was adopted by the council in 2014 now
that's a few years ago to some of us but
in in local plan and policy terms this
document is reasonably up-to-date it's
sound and it and is fairly young and
fresh
we carries substantial weight in
decision-making in planning the strategy
of the council is to make provision for
employment land in the right place near
the airport to obviously benefit from
that need for businesses to associate
with each other and also take the
benefits that the airport provides the
site is ideally suited to commercial
development and the council should be
courses cautious at losing it to
alternative uses thus undermining the
whole purpose of the plan and the
strategy behind it the applicant has
provided views from local commercial
agents that support the applicants
position you'll have seen set out in the
report before you they say there is
currently no effective demand for built
office space and in their view that
supports the applicants proposal but
members will see the council's planning
policy officers as well as our economic
development colleagues
however draw from the independent review
of the need for office space in the
South Essex economic development needs
assessment or the Edna which was dated
in 2017 which nevertheless identifies a
severe under supply of space relative
to demand so you've got conflicting
information there you've got the
documentation evidence base that we rely
on saying that we should provide you've
got these advice from consultants for
the applicant suggesting that new things
have moved on and changed and that this
would be excessive officers at the
moment take the view that because of the
age of this plan it's fairly young and
that commercial developments normally
take their time to come along and like
residential developments which have a
high profit and therefore a very fast
turnaround right commercial development
has always traditionally taken a long
while if you think of the Ross line
development where the wimpy housing 200
houses or so winning quite quick then
Along Came the school and the Sports
Center and then the Asda store came
along much later that's not unusual when
you're dealing with commercial
developments it would therefore take
very strong circumstances to depart from
the development plan and you'll see that
at the beginning of the report the
planning history explains that outline
permission has been granted for the
commercial use this site before you
tonight also has permission for
commercial development that accords with
this joint area action plan officers
therefore consider that as it strongly
conflicts with the development plan the
reason for refusal that was before is
not set aside and therefore still stands
the second reason for refusal speaks to
the sustainability of the development
it's a purpose of the national planning
policy framework to advocate sustainable
development that is both socially and
environmentally sustainable that means
that people will continue to use it and
it's also making best advantage of the
resource we have in this case the land
and the synergy with the existing
commercial developments and future
commercial developments the strong
residential nature of the developers
would not sit comfortably alongside
adjoining commercial developments we saw
on the the other plan don't jump to it
but there are surrounding other
commercial interests so you would have a
residential type use that would be
nestled straight alongside future
commercial provision
and we consider that that would not not
be good planning it would not rest
comfortably with that the revised
planning guidance of 20 of this year the
members asked us to to account because
at the time that came out roughly at the
same time we did the report it does seek
that councils take into account
provision for the elderly and provision
for care but in a planned way and in the
release of you say your emerging local
plan it asks you to take account of it
members will know that when you produce
your local plan you rely on an evidence
base and documents and we're saying that
the the Edna didn't really strike out
that there was an immediate need for
provision way over and above provision
of housing more more generally it's
right that care is provided but it
doesn't Trump the commercial need around
the airport environment that adopted
plan there has stronger carries more
weight and when you weigh it up against
government advise office is advising you
that the provision of the commercial
development should take greater weight
than the residential provision even if
Rochford had a specifically identified
unmet need okay for specialist housing
that would have to be weighed against
these other considerations such as the
importance of the airport area and
therefore officers feel that that reason
on this case still stands members will
also see from the report that whilst
there is an acknowledged need for some
local care provision the proposal in
this case would be dominated by
accommodation with care that if allowed
would in addition to other developments
such as 60 assisted living units granted
in Roche way and another 12 at timber
Grove in Raley in this case the spread
and concentration of the accommodation
proposed would be imbalanced and would
conflict with your policy age 5 which
seek'st seeks to mixer a better mix of
dwellings and that on-site opportunities
so that reason also still stands in
terms of affordable housing members will
see that the applicant does provide the
amount that was required but it would if
approved be restricted to the over 55
now your colleagues or our colleagues in
the
of housing side have a requirement for
generic affordable housing to suit all
ages not a concentration for a certain
age group so this is a odds with that
and officers feel still that reason
still stands
finally on flood risk members will see
from the report that the applicant has
failed to provide sufficient information
to pass the sequential tests required on
flood risk grounds and then there is not
an alternative site in the district at
less risk than this one in fact the
reverse is true you've got an emerging
local plan coming through where a
facility like this might be provided in
general releases that would be for a
discussion for later where as this site
the the flood risk testing that was done
it passed the sequential test because
you can't move the airport in simple
terms if you're gonna have the airport
backed up by commercial interests the
commercial land has got to go alongside
the airport provision so a residential
scam or residential based scheme like is
proposed could be cited elsewhere you've
got a big problem if you try to provide
commercial uses for the airport if you
lose this land because the airport can't
be moved to go and join them wherever
you provide them so the reason for
refusal still stands so the
recommendation chairman his refusal for
the reasons I've touched on and a set
out in pages six point seven to six
point eight of the officer record thank
you
so usual five minutes thank you chairman
members I am NOT on behalf of the
applicant asking you to determine this
application this evening it may surprise
you that I am asking you to defer it
again and you would of course initially
be reluctant to do that but I'm going to
explain why I would suggest it is
justified in the particular
circumstances of this case to give this
matter more careful thought mr. Strang
said a few minutes ago that there is
conflicting information with regard to
the position in respect to real
commercial property demand for
development within this area allocated
in the joint area action plan
he's certainly correct about that and
you can see that on the face of the
agenda material you'll see the reports
that have been prepared for the
applicant by both Glenny and Ayres and
crooks in fact Glenny commenting on
heirs and crooks and the these two firms
are at the forefront in property matters
in commercial property matters in this
area and I would suggest that their
opinions are to be taken seriously in
addition we now know that there are
concerns on the part of Southend Borough
Council with regard to the viability of
what is currently allocated on the face
of the joint area action plan the
officers have said and in paragraph 314
of the report that you have in front of
you that there is no clear and robust
evidence to support a departure from the
development plan I would suggest that
you're entitled to disagree with that
after you've considered what Glenny and
heirs and crooks have to say there was
an issue there are very important issue
the officers have also said in paragraph
322 in the report that there aren't any
material considerations
justify a departure from the development
plan well that depends on the weight
that you give to the material that has
come forward from heirs and crooks and
from granny I would suggest that their
evidence can't be dismissed out of hand
if that's right well then there are some
material considerations that justify a
departure from the development plan you
don't need to go any further than
paragraph 120 of the National planning
policy framework to see that what I'm
saying is correct
it says planning policies and decisions
need to reflect changes in the demand
for land they should be informed by
regular reviews of both the land
allocated for development in plans and
of land available and land availability
and it goes on to say at be in the
interim prior to updating the plan
applications for alternative uses on the
land should be supported where the
proposed use would contribute to meeting
an unmet need for development in the
area that's where we are in our
submission so far office of ours this
site is concerned we say there is an
unmet need and respective retirement
accommodation and here is an opportunity
because the allocations are not being
taken up if you consider this area no b1
allocation has been taken up this is a
2014 adopted plan based on information
which was gathered in the latter part of
the 2000s in fact you can see in the
footnotes in the plan that much of it
was based on material that was gathered
in 2009 2010 and we suggest that this
matter what to be looked at very
carefully whether it's looked out now or
in the future it's going to have to be
looked at fairly soon everybody in this
room who's taken any interest in this
particular area knows that there hasn't
been any b1 development on the site and
the the plan was adopted in 2014
I appreciate what mr. strengths has to
say about lead times for commercial
development but this really is something
that deserves looking at carefully our
point is you should look at it carefully
what you should do is to defer now first
if you haven't already made yourselves
familiar with the site though
look at it but second why not convene a
roundtable meeting where you can
question the appropriate experts all the
provision that you need for that is in
your code of conduct for good practice
floor planning matters I'm sure you're
familiar with it it is your paragraph e
do contact the assistant director place
an environment where you think a formal
meeting with applicants developers or
groups of objectives might be helpful
and at the foot of the page do ask
relevant questions for the purposes of
clarifying your understanding of the
proposals now this is a clear case where
the issues involved merit you getting
really involved in informing yourselves
and questioning the experts obviously
with officers present in accordance with
your code of practice thank you thank
you this has been bubbling around for
quite some time I have a number of
concerns with with the development the
the principle and the idea of the
development I don't have a problem with
it's the location we have a joint error
action plan with Southend which
allocates this as industrial employment
land if we are to remove that or change
that allocation that leaves us wide open
for other areas to be the same that's my
first concern
secondly that it is a flood plain area I
believe an officer's will correct me if
I'm wrong here I believe its floodplain
3 because of the Rogue Valley river that
runs through there I'll ice great is
that the right way around I could never
remember this right way around chairman
the only part of the site is in flood
zone 2 & 3 so there's various flood so
one is the area where development should
go with the least risk yeah flood zone 2
obviously in the middle then 3 is the
most risk I can never remember which way
round it is the other thing are
concerned about this site if you wants
to go forward is that it will become
very isolated there is no bus routes
running through through that area we've
been trying to negotiate with bus
companies with regards to the haul road
development and they are very very
reluctant to even with that in place to
bring you forward so I'm very concerned
about the isolation of the area other
things that if the committee is of a
mind to agree to the matter I would like
to see than to take into account is with
a number of 106 agreements particularly
around footpaths there is a tunnel that
runs from which the old railway of
tunnel it runs from the original site
through to Cherry Orchard Park I'd like
to see some funding put forward to
improve that because that would be
something that residents if they are
there would be the case and there's no
interconnection of footpaths from the
site to goes right through to Rockford
as there is no bus service I suspect
people will want to walk or cycle so
again some funding for that side of
things
whether we can actually agree to some
funding for bus services I'm not certain
about through 106 agreements but that's
something that perhaps that out also
Walter will take into consideration but
I would like to ask the committee to
seriously consider not to defer this
again I don't see really the point the
main reason that they're my opinion that
there's not much call for B 1 use at the
moment is because of what is happening
nationally and that once the issue of
the National issues which I'm sure we're
all very aware of are resolved and our
economy starts to change I believe that
that that issue will change Thank You
chairman thank you divert revoir other
to non-members we should speak for sure
Thank You chairman I disagree with times
with Steptoe and as much as I think this
actually should be deferred if we airing
that Southend are looking again at
what's happening on the commercial side
of it perhaps we need to know their
thought before we go ahead with anything
and probably we should have a site visit
and see what's going to happen and they
just I say I move that we actually defer
thee okay sure
that's Lucas scale
Thank You chairman I must admit I tend
to agree with both councilor Steptoe and
councilor sure but you're saying that
it's away from totally away from other
residential areas there is a strip of
occupied housing that this would back
onto in the old Cherry Orchard Lane not
Cherry Orchard wife so I don't think it
would be quite so much out of places as
is implied also there is another
entrance site although it is blocked off
at the moment I think it's shown on the
plan there just above the roundabout yes
that could be very dangerous if it was
opened up thank you I'm just listening
to what counts the Shah said about the
deferment I I'm not in favor of
deferment at all on this we've we've had
an application but to us we have
deferred once for clarification and that
clarification has been offered to us in
detail if the applicant wasn't happy
with us making a decision it was it's
it's for them to withdraw it so I think
we should be making a decision tonight
cancer Stanley Thank You chairman
there's two things that really I am
worried about
with this application is that how are
you how is the mitigation going to be
for the that entrance that mr. strengths
delivered on not being usable which I
feel that it can be used and there we
know police in off their entrance and
the other thing is that being so close
to the airport I would have thought that
this was ideal as an industrial site
rather than a residential for the noise
that's going to come from other be one
is it be one premises it close to that
so I and the traffic that he's going to
be delivering and working around the
airport and that that there'll be too
much for nobly residents so put over 55
I'm not sure that the over 55 is one a
quiet life and not one with a busy life
with the airport above them however
having said that there some lights to do
airplane spotty I suppose but getting
away from that I don't think that this
the whole concept of 2010 when the
information was gathered is not up to
scratch
this is 219 now 2019 and no I don't
think it should be looked over again it
should be dealt with in in the right
manner of up-to-date statistics thank
you thank you I'm not going to suggest
at all that this is a speculative
application it's had a lot of work go
into it but but equally the development
of the [ __ ] had an awful lot of work go
into it and I don't believe that this
application is substantiated by the
level of detail
examination and submission of evidence
that all aspects of our Japanese our
core strategy have and in countless
Stanley's suggested a retirement village
complex whatever you you like to call it
next to a busy commercial industrial
side doesn't sit well with me and this
development of residential accommodation
being so far away from our town centers
within the district again doesn't sit
right with me so uh on that basis with
the items that have previously been put
forward for refusal and with the revised
examination of the the more recent
issues that were presented to as and the
clarification on the highways I'm
certainly going to be quite happy to
support the officers recommendation
which is printed on six point seven so
members I'll move to that the this item
be refused based on the recommendations
for refusal to printed on page six seven
and six eight those members in favor of
the refusal please indicate
those against that item is refused okay
item seven
which is land to the east of the Rugby
Club Aviation way Rochford moving this
one thank you
[Music]
Thank You chairman okay and this
application relates to cherry the
Business Park just off Cherry Orchard
way sorry I will and I thinking and this
application site or this application
relates to the Business Park of Cherry
Orchard way the application site itself
is located south of the access road and
the access road I mean this application
does follow on from an outline planning
application that was granted in 2015 and
the access road and a roundabouts as you
could see in may well be aware are
already in place and the site itself for
those access road and this application
reserved matters and it's phased to
within the business park Phase one
related to the I Pico building which is
under construction at the moment in the
southeast corner at the safe this
application relates to a free story
building and they seeking a sense for
the appearance of the building the scale
the layout access into the site and
landscaping and as you can see from the
plan for you the building is a sort of
angled rectangular building and there's
some two blocks the building that is
connected centrally you can see the car
parking is laid out along the eastern
flank part of site there's extensive
landscaping throughout the site the
building will be free stories in and
measuring 14 meters in height it's quite
it has a quite modern appearance the use
of the building be used for be one sort
of it office and general industrial with
this there will be a cafe which would be
ancillary to the main use there'll be
areas within the building that would be
used for meeting rooms breakout areas
the car parking on site as you can see
is along the eastern flank boundary
they are proposing and both disabled and
electric charging points not together in
the same car parking space so and so as
you can see as I zoomed in you can kind
of see it's saver car parking spaces
here electric charging point spaces here
up here are for sort of two wheelers and
also there's a large amount of of cycle
parking that's been proposed in the
building and outside the building
there's going to be eighteen cycle
spaces internally and I think
thirty-four externally so I mean this
site itself and is promoting kind of
sustainable form of transport for the
area and the car parking and spaces
associated with the development does
comply with the car parking standards it
proposes 107 car parking spaces these
all do measure to the dimensions of the
car parking standards and this
application has been recommended for
approval and as it is considered to be
in accordance with the [ __ ] that's
currently in place this area and the
remainder of the development plan as
well as the MPP thank you thank you
pepto Thank You chairman I'm pleased to
see this application coming forward two
reasons one is it does comply with our
joint area action plan or jet report and
does show a need for some b1 use within
the area I would like to ask the
committee if they would also consider
some 106 agreements around the use of
the site particularly with access to
Cherry Orchard Park we're going to have
lots of people there working
particularly through the summer months
that will be wanting to have access
through to Cherry Orchard Park again
I've mentioned the tunnel in the
previous application there is an
opportunity there that that could be
utilized
my main concern though is that where the
new roundabout is that there's not
really any crossing points for
pedestrians to cross that particular
road and it is a 50 mile an hour Road
the Cherry Orchard way so I would be a
little bit concerned about that another
site did originally have connections
with four cycles etc but I would like to
see some some 1:06 money again put aside
to help improve psychic connections
particularly through to Rockford station
in particular and also through to cherry
to the aviation way side of things as
well where the buses do actually stop at
that end of the German that's I would
ask committee to consider those
particular items if they would please
thank you could I ask for a comment on
chairman members will see that the
application is a reserve matter
application which is the second half of
a planning consent so you outline plan
and application that comes forward in
the first instance normally brokers all
the initial issues of principle the
authorities that require contributions
such as highways etc they say what they
need for the quantum of development
permission is then granted the agreement
is formalized and signed up to by the
people taken over the site just leaving
the submission of the detail and this is
what you have here tonight you have
detailed submissions for a part of the
site whereby the people running the site
already know what they've got to provide
by my way of contributions and other
infrastructure submissions now
unfortunately I'm not privy to the
outline permission that goes before this
but as a matter of principle to now ask
for further contributions I think we'd
be bordering slightly on the unlawful
because they've already had the quantum
of development go through the system and
all the contributing authorities have
said we need this we need that we need
the other and this council has embodied
those hopefully in the legal agreement
now if there was something unusual about
this application that required a
contribution over and above what's gone
on before and I don't know that there is
then just exceptionally that might if
you luckily be justified but I'm
concerned that there's been an outline
that's gone before that's asked for
certain things so the the developers
know they don't need to provide any more
it's all been considered it was done at
the
line stage all we got to do is submit to
the council what the buildings are now
going to look like the details having
the confidence in the outline permission
that everything we need to do is being
done or we're obligated to do through
the agreement so I would caution members
that the the essential need for these
contributions over and above as good as
an as merit as they may do we may find
unfortunately between us I don't think
we're familiar with the outline Katie
Katie isn't here tonight who probably
would have been and can't we can't
recite it off the top of our heads but
there are bound to be contributions in
the outline permission already whether
they cover the things that members have
suggested is maybe another matter but
even if they don't there is an issue
that the outline permission has been
granted it's gone before in all these
principle issues and therefore what's
before you now is this the second
detailed part as it were for this
particular plot thank you thank you
members we do do need to be very mindful
of that specific advice clear and
specific advice for officers oh no no
man was really indicated on this so
that's a new pot sorry yeah yes you can
as a visiting member may I just asked a
quick question of mr. Franks and just to
fill a slight gap in my knowledge mr.
Franks if this was at the outline and
planning permission stage would we
actually be able to request section 106
for crossings or would that be down to
highways because I was led to believe
that would be a highways matter chairman
it is essentially a highways matter but
I mean if we got into some kind of
conflict we could always defer to go and
seek advice from legal I've known cases
where members have failed it a good idea
to put say a Pegasus crossing in which
is a zebra crossing for horses and found
that they can't implement it good idea
as it might have been because the nature
of the design doesn't suit the safety
audits the highways could never achieve
it so that the request was required and
wouldn't be able to implement that's
where when highways asked for things
there's obviously given it thought as to
whether it would work and whether it's
essential now if this was an outline
permission and members were of the view
that
you know that's essentially required it
allows permeability to open spaces
things like this which all helps that
would probably be a reasonable request
and would it be entirely dependent on
highways because it would be probably
landscaping enhancement but if there was
an element of danger to it despite that
the gesture is best often to have
highways view so it would normally be
instigated by highways or possibly
eliminated by highways before they give
you their representations but if members
felt strong enough had this been an
outline application it's probably
something we could see clarification
from them okay non-members want to say
anything okay now to the committee
Hausa Stanley you'd indicated for us oh
yes thank you chairman yes there is that
I would like that investigated if a
crossing could be put across there
across the highway and also I don't
remember the first application with so
many cycle parking spaces it's the road
as the road got a cycle runway to it for
for the cyclists to get to to come in
the other thing that we've got a hundred
and two I think parking spaces do we as
there is as far as we know so far that
there isn't any transport from buses etc
is that adequate is that an adequate
figure 102 for how many people are
actually going to work on that site my
concern is that if parking is allowed
outside of that side it will somewhat
block the roadway at 50 miles an hour
could could end up with a few problems
there
so could we can we find out that if it's
adequate or not as for the building yep
I think that it's an admirable building
it looks very nice to work in it's
better than what it's been like he'd out
before and I'm quite quite pleased to
see there thank you that's Reeves thank
you
can I just clarify the classification of
this development is for office space and
industrial right industrial like
industrial so we've got the ground floor
that we saw on the plan that was up
there that's obviously that that's
obvious the ground floor I think the
concerns may is that yeah it looks very
pretty building in that but if you're
getting light industrial you could get
engineering companies and the likes
underneath there and that can be quite
noisy on occasions if you've got Class C
offices where the the client here is
going to be trying to put this forward
as a very high spec office I'm not sure
or the viability of the offices under
over-the-top of light industrial it just
seems a mishmash allocation chairman if
I may the designation of light
industrial one of the criteria is by
reason of vibration dust noise or grit
and what they mean is a light industrial
use is not very noisy one good example
was when we used to repair television
sets
you know soldering iron you got some
bits and pieces and that beyond making
any noise if you're doing things what we
call in the trade metal bashing and if
you're making components and parts and
you're using machinery that tends to
drop you into the B to use okay so as a
guide for members understanding a light
industrial use would be the sort of
thing you might find acceptable in a
residential area now a good example is
if you look at the Royal Bank of
Scotland building at Tesco on Prince
Avenue that is a B one use it's not the
High Street office like solicitors or
somebody might have in a town centre
where there's visiting members of the
public as such it's like a call center
opera
things like that now that's a good
example of a B one use if you have
somebody doing an industrial activity
that isn't very noisy that if it was
happening in the property next door in
the street he probably wouldn't hear it
that's equally the kind of measure of
the noise activity with a B one use I'm
not sure though if even in building rec
terms if these people when they're
fitting this out they'll probably be a
need for some insulation between the
premises anyway but the B one use would
only allow them a relatively non noisy
industrial activity whatever that may be
if that helps check thank you that's
roughly can cater to shrink that so I
don't see the entrances
halfway
I'm so I'm leet wrestling the road
layout some cities out there I think
just need to have just come on you were
okay we're looking at reserved matters
arising from appearance landscaping the
layout and scale yes fine he answers my
questions you've seen more than as
Williams yeah Thank You chairman
knowing this area as I do there was a
casual crossing out across this road
until very recently and I believe that
Essex have closed it off
that's counselor Steptoe said this is a
50 mile an hour limit I would hate to
see her crossing the only I think it
would be extremely dangerous I would
like to see this tunnel opened up I
think this this particular development
is best place to speak about this and I
would hate to see this you deferred
because of that she's a great
development thank you I do really think
we're we're straying off what's in front
of us and as I mentioned earlier we need
to take great heed of the officers
advice on that one remembers I think we
we need to go to a vote on this one now
we have a recommendation for approval on
page 7.1 going through - so at seven
point three and ask those members in
favor of the approval to indicate okay
oh that's unanimous
thank you however my mindful of what
members have said just for information
could we perhaps drop members a note
later on to to explain traffic issues
crossing issues that were covered as
outlined stage thank you
right next one is item eight which is
land to the rear of three 245 Alexandra
Road great Wakering this one's to us a
second time as well who's taking this
one Katie again thank you it's me again
okay and this application became was
before committee last time in August and
this application site is to the east of
Aleksandra road and behind sort of main
behind residential dwellings in great
way Corrine
[Music]
planning permission is being sought for
the demolition of 39a alexander road or
aleksandr street sorry and they're
proposing 25 residential dwellings and
they also proposing to lay out a road to
serve the development which will gain
access from alexander road car parking
will be laid out as well for the
dwellings and also visitor car parking
and also mix your sort of landscaping as
well there will be a mix of one two and
three-bedroom dwellings comprising of
detached image attached the terrace
properties and before you kind of gives
you an indication of what the appearance
these dwellings will look like and there
will be eight affordable housing units
that are proposed as part of the
development as well these will be
clustered to the north and south with
the site all plots would have two car
parking spaces and part from the
one-bedroom unit it's being proposed
office Li that will just have one car
parking space and they all do measure to
the to the damage and set out in the
parking standards that's it there's also
visitor car parking space that's been
provided as part of development all the
dwellings do comply with the nationally
described space standards as well the
rear gardens also comply with the
council's SPD to housing design taking
you back to the ground floor plan and
there is sufficient distances between
the proposed dwellings as well as the
existing surrounding dwellings and so
it's not consider the developer would
have a harmful impact on existing
occupiers of the residents long
Alexander Road and also is considered
that 25 dwellings could be accommodated
on the site and given to all the
dimensions and the Scout bulk and a
height of the dwellings are considered
acceptable the application was
previously deferred from last committee
on the basis of ecology
himself Essex parking partnership
comments open space and status of the
land so if I take you for each one
individually and there was an ecology
report submitted with the application
that related to great crested newts and
reptiles and the first sort of report
was bit inconclusive so they at the
council went back see applicants sort of
further ecology report and that
concluded and that there were or there
are no great crested newt or reptiles on
the site or present on site also a bat
report was submitted with the
application and also there's no evidence
of bats roosting in the buildings
presence that when I referred to
building presence I mean the app catered
when that's been demolished 39a and they
carried associated with that dwell name
himself Essex parking partnership were
consulted and these aren't a statutory
console table they were consulted anyway
regarding what the parking in their area
and unfortunately Southwest Park in
partnership had no comments make for
this for this particular site or the
surrounding roads and open spaces
previously refer to recreation grounding
in brokering that is incorrect and
that's now been corrected to state great
Wakering recreation grounding in the
report and given the distances from
where that is situate from the site and
also stay to the land and this land
isn't in the Greenville is currently an
alone allocated piece of land in the
allocations plan and so therefore there
is no particular use it's not allocate
for a particularly use the site isn't
being considered as proofs developed
land because it was previously used as a
nursery and in equal to the MPP F this
isn't previous developed land however
last eighties an analytic ATP's land
it's not in the Greenbelt and this use
that has been put forward for the
dwellings residential use is considered
acceptable for this site this
applications still recommended for
approval and as it's felt that it's in
accordance with the development plan as
well as a national planning policy
framework
and has been recommended for approval
subject to conditions that already set
out in the reports and section 106
country to contributions licensed to
affordable housing rounds contribution
and schools yes a little bit thank you
thank you
I've one speaker on this item I just
want to speak really briefly just focus
in on the reasons why the application
was deferred today so one of the main
reasons was open spaces and Katie's
already mentioned the error in the
report and also there was concern about
the amount of public spaces so in the
period since the last meeting we
produced an open spaces drawing which
identifies all of the public open space
areas both free and membership-only so
it it shows that there's a wide variety
of different park spaces and different
uses or within close proximity to the
site and a short walking distance
so hopefully that alleviates any
concerns regarding provision of open
spaces secondly we talked about parking
provision quite heavily in the last
meeting so whilst the scheme is
completely policy compliant the size of
the bays are policy compliant and the
level of visitors parking is policy
compliant there was concerns raised
regarding the incorporation of a new
junction of Alexandra Road and the
impact that had on loss of on street
parking on Alexandra Road so we produced
this drawing in the last period just to
show the loss of spacing equates to two
but the new adoptable roads within the
site
have the opportunity to provide eight
new on street parking as it's adoptable
it's open to anyone to use that that
road full parking so again hopefully
that alleviates the concern regarding
loss of on street parking when we're
looking at a net gain overall talked
about the ecology report and hopefully
the concerns raised about the lack of
one has been addressed and shieff had a
chance to flick through the original
report finally I just just want to
finish from those concerns raised
regarding demolition and works
undertaken on site prior to the
application being submitted so just
wanted to clarify what that work
entailed when the applicant first got
access to the site it was quite
overgrown there were existing glass
houses to the rear parcel of the site
they had broken glass a tree was growing
through one there were signs of access
on site by other people so through
consultation with their health and
safety advisors they were recommended to
remove the glass houses and clear the
site to allow consultants access to
topographical the ecology surveyors on
site the front portion of the site has
not been touched the house is still
standing so it was just site clearance
for safety reasons so just just to
finish I hope you can support the
application a lot of thought and hard
work has gone into making it a scheme
that is fully policy compliant and well
thought out thank you very much thank
you thank you chairman is it working yes
I'm sorry I'm just going to touch on a
couple points that the speaker raised I
don't accept
at all the reasons for clearing the site
the site was cleared whether there were
green houses or
there there was no respect for the
environment and the habitation that were
there okay so I just want to clarify
that now um if the committee could
please go through their papers with me
because you might want to make some
notes
I can't ask questions of the officers
but you can page eight point six point
17 hmm prior to development and a method
statement for the installation of the
no-dick shall be submitted and approved
in writing by the local planning
authority make cetera who will be the
opera cultural supervisor be as there
needs to be some degree of assurances
for the residents this developer has
shown no concern for their well-being so
far so I would like to see this as a
council directive to be able to provide
the supervisor page eight point seven
point twenty-one it has the hours
permitted there please read through them
so it's monday to friday 7 a.m. to 7
p.m. for general works this is an infill
site this backs on to families and
families with young children who are
probably in bed before that time please
read those times these are totally
unacceptable
as I mentioned it's an info it's
surrounded by homes the officers know
the issues their enforcement team
already face in managing sites to comply
with the times these definitely need to
be reassessed I would suggest 9:00 to
5:00 for weekdays would be more than
acceptable allowing residents respite
from building site noise literally in
their back garden I know one local site
already has issues with the language
from site staff and I don't want my
families to have to put up with that
no weekend works and no bank holidays
page 8.4 3.31 just your an attention to
the fact it says he is not sorry I've
never gone out of sync little bit I have
no it's it's not considered that the
proposal will have a detrimental impact
upon the private and mean empty of the
occupiers of these properties in
relation to having an overbearing or
overlooking impact
all I can say is absolutely rubbish of
course it's developments going to have a
detrimental impact so that's actually
just incorrect page 8.17 0.3 point 4 for
ECM about the access to the spine Road
the speakers just said that there will
be confirmed a further 8 on street
parking spaces made available I don't
know how a condition can be put in that
that is recorded and that it isn't taken
away when residents moving in want to
put a stick up a private road at the
start of it or start policing themselves
I would also like to officers if
possible through the committee to
confirm that that parking will not
obstruct any large vehicles that need to
enter the site such as au amenity
vehicles refuse Norwich lorries
emergency vehicles etc 3.45 also on
there and educate parking so this
actually covers 0.25 spaces and they
have provided that there is no more I
can do about the parking on site page
eight point eight three point five one
and three point five four when covering
the replacement of trees and shrubs it
would be good to see an actual number
are we removing ten trees and replacing
with two more
details please 3.56
quite an interesting one this he refers
to the development being in flood zone 1
as identified in the Environment Agency
Maps perhaps the committee would like to
ask of the officers the date of these
maps I say this because this council has
signed out to the climate emergency we
the local councillors know that the
climate will affect the classification
of flood zones how old is this data that
officers are referring to are we the
council prepared to accept this data you
might want to at the same time on this
subject
refer to page eight point 20 there's the
report there from natural England which
appears to take a much more sensible
approach have a look at three point six
seven then there's three point five nine
regarding foul drainage so Anglia
Walltown Anglia water don't live locally
and they don't understand the problems
this area already faces and yet Anglia
water are saying they have no objections
on that one I just despair because
anybody who lives anywhere near that
road knows the problems we have with
drainage we're then going on page eight
point two one point three point seven
five relating to the substation and it
reads as a substation building is not
considered to have a detrimental impact
this is situated to the rear of number
thirty-nine so I ask anyone in this
chamber would you want a substation
built at the back of your home of course
it's going to have a detrimental effect
on that resident
now I have a question that perhaps the
committee could put air to the officers
regarding the affordable rent properties
should this application be approved I
don't know if there's a condition that
can be added for these to being looked
at being managed by a local social
housing landlord because although
whoever takes them over we would have
100% nomination rights in the future
it's always easy a long term to work
with local social housing landlords when
there are issues in the future with them
just one last point there is a mention
of there will be provision for all our
site vehicles to be parked on site
perhaps the committee could ask the
officers how this would be policed I've
already got issues in another part of my
ward and there are they going to have
the six parking spaces that going to be
provided which I meant to be for the
residents because I can guarantee you
they will be parking on the road Thank
You chairman that's a step toe thank you
cheering most of the bits of pieces I
was going to raise from councilor next
to me has already raised a couple of
cover questions I would have to suggest
the committee need to ask one is with
regards to the substation substations do
make noise I'd like to know how that is
a mitigated they if anybody's lived near
one
as I have done in the past maybe they
make a sort of continuous buzzing noise
how do they how do they mitigate that my
main concern is still is around the
parking those that no Alexandria Road
know that it is a very narrow road my
concern is how are they going to deal
with deliveries of vehicles and bringing
in materials what happens if they turn
up before the working hours where do
they go they certainly can't park in the
high street because that's bad enough as
it is and there is no space in Alexandra
row
so that something needs to be considered
and I would ask the committee to perhaps
consider that within the scenario other
than that shame and that's it thank you
okay thank you sure
Thank You chair Daniel cross that he put
in plans to our regarding showing the
open spaces have we got that please
that's all just quoting what he said he
said he put in showed you a plan with
all the different open spaces around the
area have we got that please but that
doesn't like sure show where the open
spaces are for these this 2520 what they
could use all just asking if we've got
the plan because it was someone's if
someone's actually said these they are
just one if we actually had it can you
send us a copy thank you that's the
Stanley Thank You chairman according to
the page I'm eight eight point one five
we have ten properties with four and
five bedrooms and yet we're told that
there are only two parking spaces for
those homes
[Music]
I've got Aaron Sadie's got a people
three or four parking spaces at least on
the basis that they'll be for four
bedrooms there will be a grown-up family
there eventually whether they move in
straight away or whether they start off
as young people so I'm not happy with
that at all on the basis that they would
have to put their cars somewhere else
and that may be in aleksander Road which
is another sort of parking issue which
may arise later on also the size of
rooms although the minimum and these are
it seems as though
we're just over the minimum required by
the space standard and some of them are
just about on the minimum there's a
three bit that I can see is just on the
minimum could is there any way of
rectifying that to bring it up to a
little bit of a higher standard
especially where we've got a three bed
and it's just on that minimum size is
that is that just the requirement we ask
of a developer to go for a minimum size
or can we ask for something a little bit
larger than just the minimum size on the
basis that like everybody else that they
need as much room as they can get hold
of and obviously the site is is he's
built to a minimum size or minimum
standards I'd like to see a little bit
more of not being a member over minimum
if that's possible thank you
this one particular issue that stands
out to me that no one's picked up on so
far page eight point two seven paragraph
four thirty one I'll read it as it's
written it is considered by Anglian
Water the development will lead to an
unacceptable risk of flooding downstream
the paragraph goes on to say that they
will expect to work with the developer
in the future to do any work necessary
on that I think it would be quite remiss
of us to actually pass this application
without knowing what that mitigation
actually is I do say again Anglian Water
have said that it will lead to
unacceptable risk of flooding downstream
thank you that's right ft just like pick
up on a couple of our points that
counsel McPherson made one is the
parking again people who know Alexander
vote no there's parking both sides on
the pavement they've put some more
parking spaces I don't know if you've
got the plan they're casing
so whether if actually put the pocket
it's the green part isn't it everybody
can see that Mike might be worth blowing
it up a little bit you can a fraction
maybe there yeah there you go there you
go
where's I said he'd the green parts they
are I can't see it not interfering we've
large vehicles going down there I don't
know you're gonna get parking on both
sides again it's the wit for the road
this is which the road is it does it
leave enough space so excited together
we've been advised that the width of the
road is to an adoptable standard is too
adoptable standard okay okay and the
other point of God is the work times
have gotten there as it can Smurf ears
to say from 7:00 a.m.
all right through to seven o'clock in
the evening especially with young
children living in ours is just
virtually on the site it's an especially
of other sites for a downing wait why
Queenie it's caused a lot of problem
with noise and not quite language and
stuff like that maybe WebAssign we need
to look at a future for infill sites
it's maybe make that starting a little
bit later Mike you up on the other end
maybe
[Music]
it's loads of and also I think we've got
a lack of information as councillor Shaw
said where's what's happening with the
open spaces on the site I know there are
gonna be open spaces somewhere but it
doesn't actually really show and what's
meant by private open spaces and
probably open spaces I know it says down
by the recreation ground public gain is
quite unclear so I wouldn't mind
actually defer any since we get the
proper answers on this Thank You
chairman there seems to be another one
I'll answer questions and in even
significant amount of unanswered
questions and I would like to propose
that we defer this once once again
forward I think if we could take some
answers from our officers first please
and particularly stress around the
traffic management issues and at the
anglia water yes and we've regards the
Anglin water point and you have written
correctly in the officers report but
these there are conditions that have
been imposed it relates to the drainage
water strategies which are conditions 4
to 4 to 6 so this requires further
information so that adequately deal with
angler waters concerns and so luckily it
is covered by conditions relating to the
car park in that council Stanley raised
and I know four to five bedrooms and I
know you have concerned I was a lack of
car parking however they do provide
these houses do have two car park is
based allocated to them and that is in
accordance with the highway the parking
standards that have been adopted so they
do comply with that room size is also
and I know you don't appreciate that
they've they've produced a minimum
however we advise to developers that
they've got to comply with with the
national space standards and as far as
we are concerned these do comply with a
national describe space standards whilst
you may not appreciate
alpha t it does comply wit for the road
is 5.5 which account safety raised and
this is tuna doctoral standard operating
hours and there has been a condition
imposed seven to seven Monday to Friday
as well within that condition there is
an eight to eight to five o'clock and so
operating from seven o'clock in morning
allows devours builders or workers to
access the site without the clash of
school traffic I think schools start
eight o'clock a half eight primary
schools and so this allows workers to
get onto site seven however they're not
actually allowed to to start any noisy
works such as concrete break compiling
pile driving an angle driving until
eight o'clock in the morning and luck
say it's 7:27
if we reduce those hours to 9:00 to 5:00
Monday to Friday and not having any
works taking place at weekend we will be
prolong in that development and that
will then go on longer than anticipated
so that's my advice on that one and
someone did mention about an
agricultural supervisor and that would
be someone that isn't and it was someone
that it would have to be LCA Richard
agricultural person be it was a
supervisor that also they would employ
themselves or we do have our counts
officer James choke would work alongside
the developer supervise any works that
are taking place to trees shrubs etc on
site I think I've covered everything
remind me if I haven't covered
everything just point you to one more
eight point two eight four point three
eight Essex police have said like to
discuss the developer crime prevention
we do we know whether that's happened or
I don't know if that's actually taken
place as yet but that advice will be
given to the developer and it's down to
developers to then contact with the
police to discuss any crime prevention
any that measures that they can put in
place to prevent
I'm from from taking place on this site
Thank You members this is the second
time this item has come before us I
think to be fair in the way in which we
administer our decision-making process
we needed to raise last time all of the
particularly pertinent issues though
that we needed to make a decision and
that that those issues were raised last
meeting and and they've they've been
answered whether to your liking or not
is another matter this time so I do
think that it is appropriate to make a
decision there's lots of points being
brought up but I I think they are more
around issues that can be conditioned or
sorted with the developer I don't think
they're fundamental to stopping a
decision being made I've got three
members that have indicated they're like
a second go Stanley first oh sorry
cancer Watson first son chairman thanks
really picking up on various points we
haven't actually had an answer but
appreciate it wasn't a member that
raised the the question of the
substation the buzzing of a substation
and I totally understand the point that
was made in earlier we haven't actually
seen the evidence of the open space
requirement which was clearly an issue
I'm really concerned about the times the
operating times with the best will in
the world people push the limits
building companies do push the limits
and we are in the middle of a
residential area I would love to see
wheel washing facilities put in because
the mud that is brought on to streets
but I think the biggest issue for me is
4.31 which is really reflecting
councillor Eve's point I don't think it
is good enough to bring a clause which
actually says the development from an
authority the development will lead to
an unacceptable risk of flooding
downstream
we see regularly now pictures on our
television screens of the awful state
that flooding brings and to have that
rather airy-fairy
well we will work to sort it out is
totally unacceptable in terms of
presenting detail to us so for that
reason I couldn't support the
application as it's currently set out
Kath Reeves Thank You chair as was just
mentioned and regarding the Anglian
water issue what my concern there is
right I said I have to apologize I
wasn't at the last planning meeting
because I was on holiday but the issue
for that with me is if we put that as a
condition on there we're talking about
downstream where does that where is it
going to effect we should be quite
reckless of us I think to actually pass
this without indication of where this
effect is going to be and what the
mitigation of those possible issues
might be it's too wide to just say yes
get on with it come up with something
and expect us to sit back and say yes
it's okay thank you
Thank You chairman I'd like to point out
that as you already know I'm very in
with this flooded thing and we have got
two sites very very local to this very
place we're sitting in at the moment
where they have mitigated their surface
water I don't see any mitigation on the
surface water from this site and as
pointed out that it's a will it happen
or won't it happen and it's a discussion
not between us and the developer but
between Anglian water and the developer
which we should be entitled to view what
the what the conditions will be and how
they will mitigate it on the basis and
also the the parking
area I do feel that two parking bays is
not sufficient for a 4 and 5 bedroomed
property
considering that you could have one
parking bay with a caravan only which
probably will have most people use
caravans there because can't afford
foreign holidays especially as the
flights have now been discontinued with
thomascook however I do think that there
should be some mitigation as to parking
off road and not on road and also to
where the amenities are for the general
use of the public therefore I cannot
support this application thank you lefty
Jen I agree with caster Stanley with the
angular water and as this developer
seems to do the bare minimum of
everything I don't really want to see
the bare minimum done with regard to
flooding especially if them they're
leaning down in great eye cream also I
like to point out to the officer that
the way Queen he's quite strange with
school times because the bus picks them
up I thinks about half past 7:00 in the
morning so the times you've got he will
clash completely with school times so it
needs to be looked at better on on where
individual places are thank you so I
can't support this reason with the
flooding chairman just to help members
perhaps with the Anglian Water comment
it doesn't strike me that's an objection
they're raised into the scheme when they
say we will have to work with what
they're try and I think to communicate
across is the drainage authority they
have a responsibility so they're
anticipating there would be a certain
outcome from the development that they
were left accommodate and manage okay no
that's what they do on a daily basis and
I think what they're trying to say is
they will have to work with the
developer they have their own
legislation that they go to the
developer
and and seek mitigation compensation or
whatever it is they have to do when
you're in implementing development like
this the planning permission is not the
only thing you need you need building
regs you need consent from the statutory
Undertaker's angling war to the drainage
authorities all these people so they're
headlining to you that they see a
problem and they're going to have to
work with the developer to fix it but my
dealings with angling water tend to be
they work in their closed environment
under the Water Act or whatever it is
they're working without I think to some
extent you can be reassured I understand
that members are concerned when they see
the danger words they're unacceptable
risk of flooding downstream the
naturally assuming and perhaps rightly
so that somebody somewheres gonna get it
and you know this this committee and
these members have have the
responsibility for it
but I think what angling water are
suggesting there is that there's
spotting a problem and outside of this
process they will go off and seek to
resolve that with the developer and I
think you'll find that the legislation
that Anglian water is empowered by
allows them to approach the developer
and fix it so you know you may see a
farmer suddenly having to widen a ditch
or something like that but angling water
says would the water course crosses your
land we need you to do this we will come
in with a digger we want 10-foot
easement or something to do that and
they undertake these works so I don't
think if you were to think well this is
unacceptable it's refused permission for
drainage reasons I don't think angling
water suddenly rushed to your defense
because we were going to do with this
you know they haven't perhaps been clear
and maybe members seek that
clarification but my understanding of
the process is angling water will be
looking to do these things under their
remit in what they do if that helps
Jimmy
Thank You chair and thank you to mr.
strength so that very helpful
clarification and that's much
appreciated and doesn't particularly
help this particular application in
terms of the words that written here but
I would have been much more reinsured
reassured to see a clause in there
saying there are a range of possible
options and we will work to resolve it
but it's rather black and white in terms
of the way it's written currently thank
you
Stanly can I remind the officers and the
committee that there is legislation and
they say something in the order of is
not permitted to put water where it's
not naturally intended so in this
respect if it's not naturally intended
to flow downstream to other occupants
then this should not be this should be
dealt with in the order of putting pawns
in or swells or whatever the case is
that you need to do to mitigate it thank
you very much members I clearly get the
feeling that this is an application that
you don't like for a variety of reasons
however we have had from our officers
clear advice and through the deferment
clarification that this application is
compliant where it needs to be we've had
some clarification about the the way in
which anglia water might might might
work when making your decision if you're
making a decision not to approve
something which we'll move to in just a
minute
then the obligation would be to make a
reason ultimately if it is not
successful for refusal and that reason
for refusal has to be substantial and
supportable so members we have a
recommendation for approval printed on
page 8.1 going through with its various
items through 28.7 those members in
favor of the approval please indicate
for those against no not at this point
five that item is lost so we now need to
move forward councillor Yves you you
wish to say something yes could I
propose that we defer the decision until
the next meeting I think we do need
clarification on the flood issue we do
need clarification on a lot of the
issues that actually come for for
fairness to the applicant yes
well I don't want the term clarification
on a lot of issues I want clarification
on a specific list of issues please
flooding and the Anglian Water proposals
because I think although I've heard mr.
strengths explanation I think with the
experiences that we are having with
flooding and now we need to know
definitely what angling water proposes
oh okay the position of the transformer
can that be moved yeah yeah or certainly
it's noise it's noise footprint yeah
what what could be done to that
open spaces baby no part of my things on
location yep
the working hours um I I think you know
Barry mom was still planning committee
and it's better it's information to
inform our planning decision okay so
members was anyone prepared to second
cancer yeah okay the members just just
be being furnished transparent all
around we're deferring we've asked for
information on flooding the transform of
the open spaces the working hours no no
this the the information for those
answers will allow you to make a full
and final decision those members in play
in favor of the deferment please
indicate okay those against all right
that's our items now deferred
so sorry not not not at this moment snot
propria
it's the way the system works
right next one is item nine lanta north
of London Road south of raw earth
there's a small a bit of information on
the addendum he's got this one
a chairman this is a reserved matters
application for a proposed change to the
siting of utility infrastructure in
association with the development
approved for up to 500 dwellings white
outline Planning Commission at land
north of London Road and south of Wharf
Lane Rayleigh in 2016 this parameters
plan shows the wider approved
development lab of site phase one of
which is currently underway so this is
the the site in its entirety and phase
one is these two beige parcels just at
the top here which are currently under
construction the development
incorporates an electricity substation
and a gas pressure reduction insulation
PRI these have previously been approved
as part of the 2017 application for
utility infrastructure at this sites but
the substation was relocated within the
residential area of phase one and the
PRI within the strategic landscaping
alongside the roar-off Lane Industrial
Estate Road they are now both proposed
to be located within a strategic
landscaping fantine War Lane so as you
can see here we've got the substation
located in just to the west of the main
access road coming into this site here
and the guest PRI to the east of it
originally we were looking at within the
actual residential area here for this
substation and the PRI which is gonna be
slightly further off map down here I'm
alongside the actual wolf from Buffalo
State Road so we're now looking at them
having fun - geez looking on - Warwick
line
oh the substation would have a man Assad
style roof and be sited approximately 14
meters from the wharf lane frontage so
that's what we're looking at here so
this would be the substation style and
that's what we will be looking at here
with the mansard style roof relatively
modest type substation and then plan for
is the gas PRI so here we're looking at
a flat roof structure again this would
be slightly closer actually to the road
approximately three meters from the
Royal plain frontage so the key material
planning considerations are layout and
design if we could just pop back to
layout two please
so the substation and gas PRI be located
in a soft landscape space but would not
be considered to interfere with this to
any substantial degree this air rip
since the substantial swath of soft
landscaping and sufficient grassland and
trees would remain within the scheme to
soften the appearance of this
infrastructure within the landscape
there was a requirement within the
approved to teach it landscaping
application for a hedge to the war flame
in front he should be retained the
current application would be like to
result in the removal of an element of
this hedging to make way for the gas PRI
and it's necessary access more a flame
this is not considered objectionable
however it will require an application
to very conditions attached to the
strategic landscaping reserve matters
and outlying applications the overall
design of the post substation and gas
POA is considered acceptable a queen who
was raised with the agent guarding
whether there is potential for
anti-social behavior
relating to the flat roof of the gas PRI
the agent has advised as follows with
just a little bit of an additional
information and from their perspective
on that they've said the PRI unit is
location or site that it's not readily
accessible on foot in a sense there is
no foot way existing or planned for the
south side of water lane in this
location and the site is not readily
accessible from the open space to the
south while so is obviously a footpath
from the north side of the lane this
isn't a location where people generally
walking past or have easy access to on
foot they also go on to say as you know
the scheme as a whole has significant
areas of open space which are much more
readily available as location to play
and youth activity and
ticular the scheme will be providing an
area specifically designed for youth
activities in due course ie there were
alternative opportunities deliberately
built into the scheme to encourage youth
activity elsewhere and then finally they
state the structures use a standardized
GRP enclosures which are used all over
the country for exactly this purpose and
designed to be robust resistant to
damage and fit for this purpose it is
also not a structure that a pitched roof
could just be added on to to try and
prevent anti-social behavior so that's
their comments on that on the
anti-social behavior point that was
raised and chairman this application is
recommended for approval subject to
conditions
yeah I'm pleased to see that they've
moved the substation away from the
residential community because I think
they do but a little bit just on with
regarding that the removal of that
hedging is that just during the
construction period are they going to
replan or do they need to leave that
open ongoingness
I think chairman I don't have any
particular concerns about the
application itself but I would ask the
members of the committee to consider
asking for a condition to be placed upon
it that any works that happen to go into
the existing highway that need to make
the connections to this that a condition
is placed upon it that the developer
and/or the utility companies need to
coordinate their work with highways and
the local planning department with
regards to potential traffic issue
mitigation around the area because
there's a considerable number of other
developments going on at the same time
so perhaps the committee would consider
asking for that as a condition
members unusually I'll just ask that
what councillor Steptoe is taking all
but verbatim and added in whatever form
is appropriate as a condition the
members be happy with that although none
of us have specifically said those words
yeah okay if I shall come back on the
hedging first yeah if you just want to
deal with those two and then we'll go to
the last of the hedging it would be a
permanent removal for that particular
section because it would enable access
from the actual raw flying and for them
to come in and do any maintenance work
that they would need to so it would be a
permanent section that would be removed
or whether there is such a large amount
of soft landscaping that we were
expecting there and that it's not
considered it's going to have a
substantial impact with that sort of
quite small section there that would
require remove all that's officers
perspective we've regards the condition
I'd just be slightly concerned about
whether it would meet the necessary
tests because we're starting to stray
into other areas requiring everyone to
sort of coordinate together that would
really be for highways and utility
infrastructure to deal with themselves
independently I would say normally I
think say you you've understood the the
will of the committee that this that
this small application as it is does not
add to the problems that have been
experienced which are quite considerable
and buy whatever the planning process is
we need to we need to ensure that this
is coordinated on on a greater scale on
to our members now then chances family
Thank You German yes I've watched this
progress of the site which there was a
ditch around the field which actually
accommodated because the field where
this is taking place has three different
elevations one towards the ROI flame
once once the farm and the other
elevation went towards the Industrial
Estate I feel that the gas unit should
be taken further back for the purpose of
people walking in the road where I feel
that there may be an extension to the
pathway later by highways and this would
cause an obstruction and I think that we
should somehow give notice that perhaps
the gas unit should be as the same
distance is what the electricity unit is
away from the highway and also on the
basis that there are lot of heavy
vehicles that turn into the Industrial
Estate and I really like I really would
like it as as accident proof as possible
by not having a guess facility put so
close to the highway that's not to turn
man to say that there won't be an
accident or will be an accident but
let's try and mitigate it as far as we
possibly can
I'd like to see there and also that the
pathway people will have to cross that
road to get on the footpath the other
side there I've got a turn man to say
that they probably won't they'll walk in
the road and I can see there being some
sort of form of a footpath going down
that side I know it hasn't had in the
past but then we haven't had 500 homes
with 500 children coming out and going
down the road
it's a walk that's walk to school at Dan
Hall Road school and I feel that we need
to somehow make provision that's what I
feel thank you numbers that the
application is for units in this
location and that that's that's what we
must determine as well
where the actual substations are due to
be the substation appear when it's it's
it's currently been approved as part of
the strategic landscaping of the overall
scheme so it's not usable amenity space
as such it's a landscaping swathe to
provide visual amenity to the scheme
quite a large expanse of it that
question was very good that they've
moved the substation and the both
stations away from the residential I
don't want to see in the future is maybe
as an infill what's happened sometimes
we need to know precisely what that land
is if it's brown field or scheduled
residential energy issues appear before
that always it the parameters plan has
approved it is amenity space not as part
of the residential site that's a Wilson
I think chairman who asked about the PRI
there's going to be some parking in
front of event for service vehicles is
that going to be completely off of the
highway
so yes just to confirm I don't know if
you can see from that zoomed in but it
would be off the highway yes members
we've got a recommendation for approval
printed on 99.1 ask those members in
favor of the approval please indicate
those again
that item is next one 10.1 application
referred from the weekly list 22 South
Street Rochford
Sherman this application is to reinstate
and convert an existing outbuilding to
provider to one-bedroom dwelling units
at 22 South Street Rochford the site is
located on the western side of South
Street we've been watched for Town
Centre and within the area covered by
the Rochford center area action plan the
site is also within the watcher
Conservation Area so as you can see here
this is the site here so we've got South
Street coming down here and the site
area is to the west and we've got a
building fronting it already and then
this is the actual building we're
referring to as part of this application
here the application site is comprised
of a three-story grade 2 listed building
which is number 22 which fronts the
streets and is in use as 12-bed sits the
Explorer s access to the site is to the
southern side of the main building and
access is a parking area to the rear
this area also contains a cycle and
refuse store the output in which the
prose relates is sited on the northern
boundary the existing outbuilding to
which the application relates is fire
damaged and disused it was previously in
use as a garage store and office so this
is the this is the building with the
existing layouts as you can see and
we've got garage in store and office
facilities here and this is what it
previously like prior to sort of being
fire damaged if we'd have planned 3kt
and this is the current proposal so the
Carroll pros will includes a modest
increase in height of the outbuilding
with a slate roof finish rebooting of
the front wall with new brickwork to
match the existing and new fenestration
along with internal works to enable the
conversion one of the units will be
fitted out to provide disabled
accommodation so the key material
planning considerations are the use
design car parking refuse for
residential amenity amenity space their
technical housing standards ecology and
trees so with regards to the use the
proposal for use of the building as bed
sets would have called with policy eight
of the area action plan which identifies
that residential uses within this part
the town center would be acceptable
looking at design the MPP F requires
that development preserve and enhance
the character and appearance of the
conservation area the county historic
buildings advisor initially raised
concern with regards to the proposal how
whether during the course of the
application revised plans were received
which removed a proposed extension and
reduce the dwelling unit numbers from
three to two as a result the county
started building the visor no longer
objects to objects to the scheme looking
at the car parking the site provides
adequate car parking and sighting
provision for the town center location
and there is access to public transport
nearby as well we're looking at refuse
the existing provision at the site would
adequately cater for two additional
units residential amenity the proposal
would not be considered to cause any
issues regarding overlooking or
overshadowing at the site the amenity
space although no private amenities
space is proposed on site there is
public open space a relatively short
walk away this is not considered a loan
to represent a justified reason for
refusal here the technical housing
standards now there's no specific sizing
requirement within the standards for bed
set accommodations that the low as it
goes down to is one bedded flats and
therefore the sizing proposed is not
considered objectionable here look in
ecology and trees the existing building
a suffered substantial fire damage and
it's considered unlikely the pros would
impact adversely on any protected
species including bats there were no
trees at or close to the site that would
be adversely affected by the proposed
development chairman this application is
recommended for approval subject to
conditions Thank You chairman I wanted
to pick up on the amenity space for this
particular site the officer has already
mentioned that there are means there is
a mean sea space in parks very close by
there is the Rochford reservoir which is
just down the road and the other one
which is the best kept secret in
Rochford
and that's Millview meadows otherwise
known as Teletubby land again in a very
short space and I think the particularly
use of this building is likely to
receive it is important for the for the
district and for the area and I do feel
that the fact that it is a town center
unit that we don't know we do not need
to worry about the community space there
are many properties within that location
particularly in fact
that do not have any amenity space
either and they've been there quite
happily for quite some considerable time
so I would ask the committee members to
not to worry about the amenity space as
there's plenty of space nearby Thank You
chairman um I've been asked to present
this statement by um councillor Christie
Mason as she's been unable to attend
tonight so I'll just read from what
she's given me here councillors mrs.
Diane Hoya mrs. Christian Mason visited
similar properties used by rockler
District Council for emergency and
temporary accommodation in West Cliff on
C and southend-on-sea and spoke to some
of the residents one of the constant and
common opinions voiced by our residents
was the value of the communal amenity
space although this space differed
greatly between the two premises and
these residents had differing needs and
histories all were in a vulnerable
situation and that communal amenity
space is permitted peer assistance and a
sense of community indeed one premises a
group Christmas meal was produced by the
residents and they were very proud of
the achievement South Street was
providing valuable temporary
accommodation was designed as
subsequently approved by this Authority
without any communal space other than a
very small out building that houses
washing machines indeed although the
rooms allow for family occupation
accommodation when councillors was shown
round prior to the occupation one of the
main concerns we raised with the
officers was both the lack of community
space and the fact that residents had no
table and would be expected to perch on
their beds or a chair which wasn't
provided and eat off their laps we do
not know these concerns was subsequently
addressed or not the existing twelve bed
seats imply 12 individuals this is not
the case as the rooms were designed for
maximum occupation indeed in the twelve
bed sits there are a total of 24 beds
and two coughs which would indicate a
possible occupation of 26 people however
officers advisors that if necessary
they will top and tail two children to a
bed so the mental image most of us have
of a bed sits accommodation one person
his way out unfortunately the average
time for families in such accommodation
is around three months however this
application seeks to provide similar
bedsit accommodation including one for a
resident with disabilities without any
provision for community support or
amenity space within the site having
read the material planning
considerations which quite naturally
focus on the physical attributes of the
application I am concerned the officers
report apparently consider the lack of
on-site amenity space acceptable this is
despite the fact that amenity space
within the area and I quote to the rear
of number 22 was indicated on the
approved plans for the conversion of
number 22 in 2016 for use as amenity
space no such soft landscape provision
has been made up on site unquote the
report states that because there is
amenities base nearby the lack of
amenity space considered is considered
acceptable as the original application
deemed it necessary I cannot see how
this conclusion is now drawn the officer
report that the car park when not in use
could be used as an informal humanity
space we're not fully occupied is
actually outrageous would you want your
children to sit and play in the middle
of a car park and next to a refuse store
would you feel safe and secure
sunbathing or resting in such an area of
course not the report states that
because there is amenity space that
because there is amenity space nearby I
am surprised that rather than enforce a
condition that's been ignored by the
council the council is recommending
approval of an intensive vacation at
this issue no community space and no
amenity space is just not an acceptable
way to house any of our residents yet
Rockford district council strategic
housing fully support this application
as they have worked with the application
on developing the other property at 22
South Street an application that is not
conformed to the planning provision I
asked this committee consider refusing
this application on the grounds of
inappropriate development by lack of
amenity space and over intensification
of the site which is already
demonstrated by the existing use of
three plus in one room or a norm of
twenty-six residents in twelve rooms
thank you listening to the statement I
can totally agree with it the problem is
we haven't got endless amount of places
and my knowledge we unless we can we
can't provide an amenity space within
this field but what we can provide for
those people who are existing already in
bed seats in West Cliff the other side
of Southend they can come back into the
district at least they're there within
their network of friends where the
schools are that their children can go
to it's a very difficult situation that
you've got to balance here in an ideal
world yes I'd want amenity space
we haven't gotten an ideal world would I
prefer people to be in this
accommodation here I think that's what
you want to ask them or likewise
accommodation the other side to Southend
Thank You council Stanley
Thank You chairman yes I've heard the
comments made however we are not trying
to put people in rabbit hutches or put
people on top of people
shoulder-to-shoulder I do feel that some
amenity space should be given I've got a
media tea space even in my front garden
that's my amenity space where I can
should I wish to maybe go out and have a
cup of tea in the garden or suchlike all
those sort of things this seems to me to
be just a room within a room within a
room there is there is no room for
anyone to breathe and are we going to
put people in this in these conditions I
know we need the housing I know we've
got so many people waiting to go on the
list and waiting for a home but do they
want to live cheek-by-jowl with others I
don't think so
I think everybody needs a practical
space and I think that this should be
refused on that basis thank you
Thank You chair I agree with counsel
McPherson this is a very very difficult
application we've got but we do need to
bring local people back into the area as
she's already stated can I ask that this
when that we if if this is approved if a
small area in the carpark could and
could we make a condition on this that a
small area could just have a small
seating area so I do believe that when
I've been around there women or men
sitting out there smoking anyway with a
little chair so it just make it a little
bit more thank you
[Music]
thank you
a couple of things quoting from the
report although amenity space within the
area in the rear of 22 was indicated on
the approval plans no such soft
landscaping provision had been made on
site was that subject to enforcement if
not why not
I'm not aware that it has been subject
to enforcement now and it's not
something that I have spoken to them
directly about but I'm not aware of it
now I said this is it this is a clear
case of going against what we as a
committee decided so I am absolutely
shocked yes I understand the point
you're making but we need to focus on
this particular running application okay
moving on then to the next sentence the
area in the rear serves as a car parking
area and could also be used for informal
amenity you see in part where the car
park is not fully occupied that is
astounding to be used as a condition
suggesting that that is going to fulfill
the amenity space let me give you an
instance if you say three years of
council say that these the children who
may be there can go and use this amenity
area which is a car park and a car
drives in there and has an accident with
the kiddy who do you think that family
are going to be suing we have then put a
condition on ourselves where we are
increasing risk hugely to the council
that is out of Aldermen to even suggest
that the car park is used as an amenity
area Magnus the other thing is to
consider that the amenity areas that are
closed should be considered as part of
this I couldn't disagree with councilor
Zepto more be honest I'd like to ask the
committee members here how many people
in this room here would like to when
they go out their door walk 200 yards to
get into their back on
it just will not happen and it will not
be regarded as such so why we are
regarding closed parks as official
amenity their areas for this is
ridiculous I would like to finish just
by quoting from our very own local
development framework development
management page six and it says in our
vision is to make Rochford district a
place which provides opportunities for
the best possible quality of life for
all who live work and visit here I do
agree with councillor Stanley here that
if we actually are putting everyone
shutting them in their rooms and no
amenity space and that is effectively
what we're proposing here that we are
not actually even taking any notice of
our own vision and I would actually
suggest that a much better use of this
development would to be to actually use
one of the properties as a communal area
thank you thank you gentlemen
councilman first to said knowing what
this property is like to be used for I
would fully support this application as
far as I'm aware that the the building
that is anticipated we will not use up
any of the land that was going to be
used for amenity space and that will
still remain and I will fully support
this thank you can I ask for an officer
comment on the viability of sectioning
off part of the parking area for a small
segregated amenity space sorry and so
with regards to the actual suggestion
with regards to the condition and I do
think I have already sort of drafted one
that we could use and as met with
members concerns regarding the lack of
immense space provision because there is
capacity still for a degree of a minimum
space on the side
and if we impose a condition requiring
details to be agreed I'm not gonna read
out forwarding if you want but it's
along those lines and then we can
require them to submit details to us to
provide an element of soft landscaping
it would be so I wasn't a point of the
plan more to do at the moment
but it would be to the the western side
of number twelve the main building as
you come in the access way there's a
parcel of land and there which we could
require and a degree of amenity space
provision on the site by condition and
we could agree details of what there was
to entire land look like Thank You
chairman
I'm quite happy to do to put that
forward as a conditioner thank you
leftie um well quite picture support
Castle Williams on this and also I can't
believe I'm saying this because I'm
usually first one to come up with
there's not enough parking spaces but
for once
this is somewhere actually in a town
centre with train bus and loads of
places people can go so I haven't got
that concerned with parking so much in
the moment thank you this one members on
ten point one point seven there is the
recommendation for approval plus the
additional condition as stated those
members in favor of the approval please
indicate you can have your name note
noted as to which way you voted so this
is in favor thank you as against you
that item is approved members we have a
moment in time where we cannot progress
we'll just hold for a minute just in
just in case members weren't aware and I
do apologize if any members of the
public been waiting this item ten point
three one two nine Ferry Road home
bridge was withdrawn
you reckon the likelihood is